ونحييكم من جديد بعد سنوات من التوتر
والخصام بين مصر وتركيا بدات المياه تعود
لمجارها مؤخرا وتتجه القاهره وانقره لفتح
صفحه جديده ولتجاوز خلافاتها فوزير
الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري وخلال مؤتمر
صحفيا مشترك مع ناظره اليوناني نيكوستنديه
اعلن انه سيزور تركيا خلال يومين لاحداث
التطبيع على اسس من حسن الجوار وعدم
التدخل في شؤون الداخليه وتحقيق السلام
والاستقرار كما وصف الوزير المصري
العلاقات مع اليونان بانها استراتيجيه
ومبنيه على مبادئ حسن الجوار وليست مواجهه
لاي اهداف اخرى وكان وزير الخارجيه التركي
مولود شاويش اوبل من جهته
ظهر القاهره الشهر الماضي في زياره هي
الاولى من نوعها لوزير خارجيه تركي الى
مصر منذ احد عشر عاما وصفها حينها
بالايجابيه والموجهه لتحقيق نتائج ولم
يستبعد وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود جاوي
اعلانات تعيين السفراء بين تركيا ومصر
خلال زياره وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح
شكري المنتظره الى انقره نناقش هذا الملف
مع ضيوفنا من القاهره الدكتور سمير غطاس
منتدى الشرق الاوسط للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
اهلا بك من اسطنبول زاهد
تركيا اهلا بكما ضيوف الكرام اسمح لي ان
ابدا من اسطنبول معك استاذ زاهد في الواقع
مسار تطبيع العلاقات بين مصر وتركيا تعلم
حضرتك كما كذلك الدكتور غطاس بانه مستمر
منذ فتره طويله ولكن ولا مره تحدث فيها
الطرفين بهذه الصراحه وبهذا الوضوح على
نوايا واجراءات فعليه لاعاده تعيين سفراء
هل تعتقد بانه هذه الخطوه هي اعلان بانه
الملفات العالقه سابقا بدات تخطيها حقيقه
في هذه الفتره
بدايه التحيه الطيبه لك ولجميع المشاهدين
قناتكم ولضيفكم الكريم ايضا
باعتقادي ان هذا المسار نعم هو مسار طويل
كما اشرت الى ذلك فاننا عندما ننظر الى
الخطابات التركيه ورغبتها في عوده
العلاقات التركيه المصريه سنجد ربما خلال
العامين العديد من التصريحات والبعض
المواقف الرسميه الحكوميه التي تؤكد على
رغبتها في عوده العلاقه التركيه المصريه
لكن واجه ذلك
من تسميته بالشروط والمطالب المصريه
المحقه بطبيعه الحال في اكثرها
وبالتالي هذا المسار حقيقه اخذ ربما نوع
من انواع التباطؤ الذي لم تكن ترغب فيه
انقره يعني ربما يمكن ان نقول ان تغيير
المسار في السياسه الخارجيه التركيه بدا
ربما في تصريحات تخص مصر ابتداء وانتهاء
لكننا شهدنا قبل نحو يعني قبل نحو في
بدايه الامر تحسن العلاقات مع دول
الخليجيه ولا سيما الامارات منها ولكن كان
من المتوقع او كان متوقع ان تكون عوده
العلاقات التركيه المصريه قبل هذا التاريخ
لكن ربما بسبب الملفات التي اشرت اليها هو
الذي اخر السبب لكن يبدو ان الكثير من
الاشكاليات او الكثير من الخلافات
تم تجاوزها او تم التفاهم على صيغه لحلها
وبالتالي يمكن الحديث ان العلاقات بالفعل
بدات تعود الى مجاريها الطبيعيه وخاصه
اننا شهدنا قبل فتره لقاء الرئيسين صحيح
ولكن ترى بان هذه الملفات قد يكون هناك
تجاوز او حلها دكتور غطاس هل تعتقد بان
هذه الملفات نتحدث على ملف ليبيا على غاز
المتوسط وعلى ملف الاخوان خاصه هل تعتقد
بانه حلت هذه الملفات او اجهلت كما يقول
البعض
لا انا اعتقد انه احد
الاسس التي تم التوافق عليها في اللقاءات
السابقه خاصه لقاء وزير الخارجيه المصري
في تركيا عندما زارها على اثر الزلزال او
زياره وزير الخارجيه التركي عندما زار
القاهره وما بينهما لان هناك اتصالات
وقنوات اخرى مفتوحه طوال الوقت ان احد اهم
الاسس هي اداره المشاكل وليس حلها اذا
استعصت المشاكل على الحل وخاصه انها مشاكل
قديمه ومعقده ومركبه وتتعلق باطراف اخرى
لانها ليست فقط علاقات ثنائيه يعني مثلا
التنقيب في شرق المتوسط ليبيا كلها ملفات
تتعلق تتشابك مع اطراف اقليميه اخرى
وبالتالي فهي اكثر حساسيه من العلاقات
الثنائيه من الملفات الثنائيه ولذلك انا
اعتقد انه تم التوافق والتفاهم على اداره
هذه الملفات ريثما يتم تطور ايجابي في كل
ملف على حده يسمح بالتقدم لحلها لكن لا
يمكن الحديث الان على حل هذه الملفات
المعقده ولكن قد يقول بعضهم بانه بالنسبه
لغاز المتوسط يمكن اداره الملف بالنسبه
للملف الليبي والخلافات واختلافات وجهه
النظر يمكن ولكن بالنسبه لموضوع الاخوان
الذي تعتبره مصر مبدئي اساسي لا يمكن
التنازل عنه في حين بان البعض يرى بان
تركيا التفت على هذا الملف فتحت حدودها
لبعض المطلوبين في داخل المصري قامت
بتسفيرهم طبعا نحن نورد هذه المعلومات
بحسب تسريبات لنؤكدها ولا ننفيها ولكن
ننقلها لمناقشتها حضرتك كيف سيتم اداره
مثل هكذا ملف ثقيل مع كل هذه الشكوك
يعني مصر كانت تتمسك بمبدا تسليم
المطلوبين وخاصه ان الذين صدرت ضدهم احكام
قضائيه في مصر الجانب التركي اتخذ بعض
الاجراءات تم ترحيل او خير قيادات من
الاخوان المسلمين بالبقاء والالتزام
بالقواعد المرعيه فيما يتعلق
باللجوء السياسي يعني بعدم الضغط على او
استخدام الاراضي التركيه للهجوم على مصر
تحديدا وجزء اغلق بعض المنصات الاعلاميه
اغلقت لكن تركيا رفضت دائما تسليم
المطلوبين للعداله المصريه الذين صدرت
ضدهم احكام وانا ربما على قناتكم اشرت في
مره سابقه انه في سابقتين حصل في تركيا
سابقه الاولى هي قصه تركي كان معتقلا في
تركيا محبوسا بحكم قضائي وطلب الرئيس
السابق الامريكي السابق لافراج عنه وافرج
عنه وفي مصري اسمه احمد عبد الحفيظ كان
متهم في قضيه اغتيال النائب العام وقامت
تركيا بترحيلهم في كل الاحوال انني اتوقع
ان يخفض الى الحد الادنى نشاط جماعه
الاخوان المسلمين في تركيا لان تركيا
اكتشفت بالممارسه ان هذه الجماعه ان دعم
هذه الجماعه لا يؤدي الى اي نتائج ترجع
وربما كانت الدعايه الضخمه المضخمه التي
استخدمت من تركيا حول 11 11
شارع المصري ضد السلطه الى اخره
ظهر انه يعني مجرد اجراء اعلامي فقط لا
غير وبالتالي هنا
اكتشفت بانه هذا الملف صحيح تقول بان ربما
هي اكتشفت في الوقت المناسب ولكن ليس هذا
السؤال سؤال
استاذ زاهد دكتور سمير يرى بانه الانسب
ويقرا بانه هناك
نيه لاداره المشاكل وليس الى حلها هل تعقد
تعتقد بانه هذا هو الاطار الذي سنكون
امامه ان كنت تتفق واراك تتفق ربما ربما
من خلال
تعبيرك هل تنجح هذه الطريقه في عوده
السفراء مبدئيا وفي توطيد العلاقه في
مرحله اخرى
يعني ابتداء نعم اتفق الى في كل ما ذهب
اليه الضيف حقيقه نحن نتحدث في نهايه
المطاف عن ملفات لا تخص العلاقات البينيه
التركيه المصريه المباشره الملف الليبي
هناك اطراف دوليه وهناك واقع ليبيا بالفعل
يجب ان يحل وبالتالي الكل يساهم في هذا
الامر ضمن تفاهمات اقليميه ودوليه
وبالتالي الامر نفسه ينطبق ايضا على غاز
المتوسط وبالتالي اعتقد انه ايضا مع تحسن
العلاقات التركيه اليونانيه لا شك انه
سيتم المساهمه في موضوع حلحله غاز المتوسط
ومع ايضا يعني التفاهمات التي حصلت بين
تركيا ودوله الامارات وغيرها من الدول
اعتقد انه ايضا اقتربنا دعنا لنقل من
الحلحله في المساله الليبيه او التفاهمات
فيما يتعلق بليبيا وبالتالي لا اعتقد ان
هذه الخلافات كانت هي العقبه الاس في عوده
العلاقات التركيه المصريه كان هناك بطبيعه
الحال مشاكل فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات البينيه
وعلى راسها كما اشرت موضوع الاخوان وغيره
من القضايا المشكله المتشابهه اعتقد ان
موضوع الاخوان الى حد كبير اصبح جزءا من
الماضي حسب الممارسات الفعليه التركيه
وربما يعني خلال الفتره القادمه مع ولكن
لماذا الان سؤال مطروح لماذا اكتشف تركيا
الان بان هذا الموضوع قد يثقلها ولا
ينفعها في شيء خاصه ان الملفت في الموضوع
ان باب المصالحه المصري التركي يتزامن مع
ابواب مصالحه اخرى وحضرتكم تتابعون ما
يحدث في المنطقه نتحدث عن مصالحه السعوديه
الايرانيه نتحدث عن التهدئه الحوثيه
باتجاه البدء ببناء شيء فهو كان تركيا
تعيد حساباتها من هذا المنطلق كذلك
يعني هي اعاده الحسابات من جهه وربما يمكن
ان يقال ان تركيا عادت الى ضبط المصنع منذ
سنوات فعليا فيما يتعلق بسياساتها
الخارجيه يعني قبل نحو ثلاث او اربع سنوات
عندما ننظر للمشهد التركي وعلاقاتها
الخارجيه سنشاهد انها دمرت دعني اقول كل
العلاقات الخارجيه سواء مع الشرق او مع
الغرب يعني لم يكن هناك دعني اقول للدوله
التركيه في الظاهر اي اصدقاء في تلك في
لحظات معينه وبالتالي من المؤكد ان العوده
الى ضبط المصنع والابتعاد يعني عقول عن
الانحراف الذي قد تم في السياسه الخارجيه
التركيه قد تم الى حد كبير اصلاحه وعادت
العلاقات خلال السنتين مع الكثير من الدول
بشكل تدريجي هنا نخص الدول الخليجيه نتحدث
عن اسرائيل نتحدث عن الكثير من الدول
الاوروبيه ايضا التي اصبح هناك تواصل
مباشر معها وبقيت مصر حقيقه
معك دكتور غط
اسيه حضرتك تعلم بان المساعي منذ سنوات
ولكن ان ياتي الان حديث وتصريح رسمي عن
نيه اعاده سفراء توقيت مهم ليس كذلك دكتور
مهم للغايه اذكر هنا بان وزير الخارجيه
السوري ايضا زار مصر ووزير الخارجيه
التركي زار مصر وكان هناك يعني توقعات اي
منهما يمكن ان يسبق الاخر العلاقات
المصريه السوريه ام العلاقات المصريه
التركيه انا اعتقد ان تركيا الاحت على هذا
اللقاء وعلى بدء تبادل السفراء انه هذا
يخدم الحمله الانتخابيه للرئيس التركي
الحالي للانتخابات كما هو معروف في 14
ايار مايو القادم
وافقت ربما على
من القاهره دكتور سمير غطاس منتدى الشرق
الاوسط الاستراتيجيه ومن اسطنبول رئيس
تحرير السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات